okay for people joining this live stream
we are talking about uh dealing array
management array handling in wolfen
language
and
to summarize where we were at last time
um as i understand it
the uh
the first thing is templated array
structures
the ability to have some way to describe
how to access what a given element there
is a raw
version of what the array is like which
is basically just some kind of array of
whatever elements they are
and then there is a templating that
allows you to basically say
you know the elements here represent
you know column names such and such and
so on because that's that um the way
that uh we were describing it
do you understand what i'm saying
we're describing
uh can somebody speak up about this
okay does anybody remember what we were
talking about last time
i think we were talking about a lot of
different things
okay
let's let's
home in on this one for a second
so the basic idea here and maybe this
data frames thing as an as a name for it
is
the
um
that what it is is so i'm going to
summarize this again
since we seem to have forgotten what it
was
i mean i hope other people remember what
we were talking about there
um
um
so the way i see it i mean there are a
few
sort of core issues that we're dealing
with here
um
okay
let's make a list of core issues
okay so core issue number one
is
accessing
arrays
uh you know
temp
framed templated whatever
framed i don't know what the right word
is for this um
is this quantity array and also like
column based
uh yeah exactly raised yes that's what
it says so this is this is
um
scaffolded
arrays
um
okay which means
an array
where
ie
an array
where there is raw storage
that
is different
from the
from the
externally visible
uh array element addressing etc does
that make sense to people
yep yeah like it has an interface that
quacks in a certain way but that is
has an outside
interface different from its internal
storage
oh yeah what this maybe i mean depending
on how this would be done it kind of
sounds like this could just be like
either an extension of packed arrays or
something like them that allows support
for
some of this templating stuff maybe also
for missing and stuff like that
right but so so implementationally
um
we would like this to be a you know
implementationally we want a single
interface to all of this
so this is kind of like we define what
is a scaffolded array
oh it supports certain operations
right and we have that with structured
array
my impression at least from last time
was that structured array is
much less structured in the operations
it supports where like each structured
array type has its own
or like
you you can't have
like
there there isn't like a set of here are
the 10 functions that a structured array
has to implement in order for it to be
quote unquote fully supported instead it
was like every function you want to
support structured array you have to
give it a particular implementation for
every structured array type
that makes sense
and also
that's the i mean that's not really true
i mean if right i mean structured arrays
are are sort of natively supported
in you know several dozen functions
right like and some of which are quite
specific like
okay
but if you
but right i mean if you if you create a
structured array then you know all your
basic things like you know part extract
etc
you know listability
come along for the ride
intersection for instance might not know
it makes no sense no it won't so if you
define
in all cases
an array is the general case so it can
always be coerced to a general array
okay if you define a new
data structure that should have
different workflows then that's probably
not appropriate
let's say that you want column-oriented
storage where you think of the column
variables as something
you know like for data frame or you want
missing data supported missing data has
nothing to do with arrays i don't
understand what you're talking about i
mean what we're talking about so but but
is it what is the purpose of this
meeting
you know is it going over what we're
going to do and and let me let me
describe this thing what we need is a
wrapper that for example for column we
would like to be able to use the same
technology for column-oriented arrays as
we do for quantity arrays
uh can i i think there is a there is one
thing that was on top of the other
notebook that we're leaving out here is
causing some confusion it's the fact
that we started out thinking about
lists of associations and associations
of lists not arrays
so
you can consider the array like the
number indexed version of this and
probably listed into that but most most
of the uh out of course stuff and so on
is going to be
more like a data frame as as roger was
saying than as a structured array
because you might want named columns
rather than numbered i'm sorry but look
look what we're talking about here with
the scaffolded arrays concept is
in the end
as it is for machine learning for
example the thing has been mashed into
what is essentially a just a regular
tensor
right with with essentially numeric
indices
right but that is not the way the user
sees it the user sees it as oh i've got
these named columns i've got units for
these columns etc am i making sense
yes yes i i i think that structure
raised a very particular case of this
idea so there are three things there are
three things that structure already
doesn't handle which are associations
ruggedness and types
and so
none of those are arrays basically okay
who cares
i mean this is what we're talking about
okay hold on
maybe the name array isn't even in here
okay what we're talking about is what
what is the what are the
the scaffolding elements
what we call wrappering over here okay
one is
naming of items
with association keys
that's one one type of scaffolding right
where where you say globally for this
whole thing with a million elements each
thing you know there are three different
named keys and i'm going to use those
right but you're not repeating those
named keys because the inner object is
just
the raw array does that make sense to
people
yeah
okay another thing is units
or like types in general
well okay types are not what we would
normally be dealing with but it might be
convenient to have uniform types
did you see what i'm saying
yeah it might be
you would have uniform units surely down
a column wouldn't you absolutely the
whole point of this okay so that it
makes sense they're similar okay
fundamental principle
you can do scaffolding when there's some
uniformity
right
if there's no uniformity
if if every element was its own
expression with whatever then you
couldn't scaffold it in a useful way
does that make sense
i think there's no h in scaffolding
that's why it's complaining
thank you
of course it could be the scaffold where
you go up to meet your end
well i don't know i think all of these
are scaffolding
okay
in any case
well one limitation with units is
our strings something that we want to
support here
yeah i bet they are okay so there's a
question mark about strings
presumably though the idea is not that
we necessarily have a fixed list of
like it seems like okay like it seems
like strings and missing
are probably more issues for packed
array or something like it
and that this other stuff
is is kind of different right because
the point being that for example missing
the question is what kind of list do we
consider uniform and right now the
answer is it's got to be uniform list of
integers uniformly you know reals you
know complexes whatever you know and if
there's a single missing in there it's
not uniform anymore so it seems like the
issue there is just with strings missing
it's just that we want to be able to
consider those uniform
right
yes exactly but that's kind of an
implementation detail you could use some
none element which matches the type but
is actually replaced right
right but the whole point is goal is
make the array quotes uniform
uh
with
with a you know let's call it a nan
style
call out
yeah in other words let's imagine go
ahead let's imagine that every time we
have a numeric array and we put nands in
it and then the scaffold says
actually what nan means is missing
uh steve when we looked into like
we started exploring possible backhands
for this especially if this i mean if
you want this to scale to out of core
most of these do support missing and nan
separately natively so that wouldn't be
fine because not designed for linear
algebra for data science so exactly
that's what i'm saying the workflows a
little bit different than linear algebra
they're related but they're not the same
so there's no such thing as missing in
linear algebra it makes no sense even
but for data science it's key
you know okay it's absolutely key okay
fine fine
fine another another important thing i
did some testing uh last week and uh
about you know storing columns with the
structural arrays like you you have a
quantity array to store a column of
temperatures and then a numeric array to
store a column of vectors and one thing
that was very slow was uh extraction
like when you take out a row
and you have to extract a number from
the quantity array and you wrap it into
quantity that's super slow
so
that's some implementation i don't know
what that is i i can't comment on well
but it's maybe important because for for
stuff i mean maybe it's important for
for whatever interface there is for this
though because for example if you wanted
to map over one of these things like if
you want to map over a quantity array
and every time it calls the mapping
function it has to turn it into a
quantity right then that's right right
right right yeah so i mean the sort of
transducer style
programming
which means at least my interpretation
of that which means you know when you
say f when you say map
f onto a scaffolded array
that the whole idea is that somehow you
not have to unpack the scout but you'd
be able to do that
you see what i'm saying that that that
the thing
is this making any sense well i think
it's normal though the f i mean if you
want to be really general the f does
kind of need to see a whole quantity
object
i agree i agree i agree i agree but that
means
like the f sees a quantity object
but it is assembled
you know a quantity object but it is
assembled you know it's like um uh
uh it's assembled for it as a as a fake
world so to speak
you know
actually stephen uh in this demo that i
have today for streaming i have such
things
okay okay interesting all right so this
is also a problem that we had to solve
for uh
for databases because most database
backends support uh date operations
natively
and sqlite doesn't so we actually
store
and compute things with the
unix times and it's completely okay
again
so
it can be done
by the way presumably dates are another
thing then to add to the list of missing
and strings
oh i guess dates are really the same
thing as quantities and categories
categorical stuff
you know if we think data science if you
think that this is a big container for
that
then
categorical stuff date stuff
um
just just go down the list of what's
what's what's there and it it has
precious little to do with linear
algebra
um you know roger can you can you give
me an example of categorical so
for concreteness
finite enumerations you know so when
people
when people fill in a form you're going
to pick from five different things let's
say
days of the week
yeah days of the week or
you know colors or
um
well we are not quite colored genders
maybe yeah genders is a good example
complicated you know some some of you
call them
you know not just nominal but some of
them are ordinal so
you know like good better best
but if you look at
you know what's what's what you what the
kind of data that you need to process
it's full of those kinds of values
you know because
a in in
many sorry i i've spaced out for a
second you're talking about categorical
data yeah
right so that's another good example of
um another d transduction
you know or something d
d what is the right word what what is
the word for the inner version
another
um well they're both transducers no and
you know both a microphone and a speaker
is a transition yes i i know roger so
what's the thing that is the the raw
you know another you know raw to cooked
transition
right
is it covariant
well yes it's covariant contravariant
something like that another raw to cook
transition would be
for categorical data
where you store it as one two three
yes right
um
maybe another thing we should talk about
is degradation like if you're doing
everything in memory native wolverine
language you can anything under the sun
but as soon as
you know you're starting to process
stuff that is bigger and that is maybe
out of core then maybe not all functions
oh but
yeah
okay i understand but you mean the data
is degraded or the functions are not
available no the functionality like how
do we communicate
listen you can't really do this on a
terabyte size data because you're
processing it on a server not here and
server does no matter
i mean in some cases there is stuff like
for there is a lot that we can do with
the compiler like if it's sitting on
your machine and it's running say on
sqlite you can use a compiled function
you can link to external functions into
a callback into the
the
you know
the kernel itself
that should work
so it is compilable then it might work
but
everything is compatible yet
sorry say that again sorry i i i is that
i said that
if you're running something on your
machine like there are databases but out
of core there are databases that have
external function
interfaces so if a function is
compilable with the new compiler then
you might be able to run it out of core
even in parallel very efficient yes
it seems like at some level i mean
can't it just fail right i mean like in
the same way that you know if you have a
quantity array and you i don't know i
don't think you can map over a quantity
array if you if you try and call math on
a quantity array it probably gives you a
message and fails i mean is there
anything yeah you can map over a
quantity array i mean okay well
there's some might normalize and
you can't do select on a quantity array
though
uh
probably you should be able to
all right there's some operations it
doesn't matter what the operation is but
you can get that right you can't select
over a quantity array or a sparse array
because those are more general than a
flat list which is what select expects
um
but so which is why we didn't implement
that
but
also something like normal right if you
take a sparse array
you know or a very large symmetrized
array right that's the symmetrized array
if it's totally anti-symmetric can
represent with one element you know n
factorial
non-zero element or n to the n
element array
you know you can normalize it up to a
certain point but after a certain point
it just says well not enough memory in
the universe
this symmetry
can i say a quick point
stephen you wrote you know uniformity of
type cf factories
that's a great assistance to making
compiled code because if you know what
the types are it's it's very helpful for
making efficient compilable code that's
and i'm sure you know that but i'm just
i'm i'm well aware right yeah okay so i
just want to bucket the things we're
talking about here okay
um
we also talked about
well we're about to see the demo from
leonard of lazy stuff
which is going to be the beginning of
this discussion of general out of core
operations
and
what we had discussed last time
is that what we think we should have
done or still do
is that
is this approach
okay
what we did do was we have
our own
special sorted entity class et cetera et
cetera et cetera functions
rather than
having the ordinary functions
operate specially on
you know indirect out of core objects
uh
steven if i may i
would like to point out that perhaps
after this demo that i make i might say
a few words in uh in favor of the
approach
that was taken for databases even though
for streaming i take exactly the
approach that you mean as a first one
yeah i i don't think it's the right
thing but um
um
you know okay
and then i just want to again in terms
of what we're talking about here
we talked about these different sources
data sources here and we're also the
other topic that we're not covering in
this meeting but we need to cover a
different meeting is generalized
disability and the whole inserting
business and so on right
which we're keen to get implemented do
we we we need another meeting for that
right we had not have or have we solved
the design for that
i don't think it's finished no we
haven't sold that
i mean it's a difficult thing to
implement in the in the
kernel because it re it requires
touching the evaluator
so so we are we are kind of scared of
going in this direction but okay well
we'll need to do so
yeah we need to do it i mean this is
something we need to do so
okay should we see leonard's demo
um
i'm ready to share whenever you are
go for it
okay
okay so um
i will try to be brief uh and um i made
this demo in such a way such a
suspicious statement leonard yes i know
i would you usually resize
yeah you stop me whenever you feel i
know i love i love leonards i will try
to be brief but we see there are 33
slides okay no no no out of these 33
slides only maybe 15 are relevant and
out of those right
okay only five are really essential okay
all right so uh should we start with
examples or should i briefly outline the
design goals in maine let's just see the
design goals but not maybe not talk
through them in great detail so
basically it's supporting lazy
computations okay we get it
okay okay good
so the ingredients are basically a list
like object called lazy list which
supports a limited subset of list api
and then some ideas that are around it
like chunking have you implemented those
yes sure
okay uh
and uh uh i can if you want i can show
you i have
data sources please
data sources uh are files potential data
sources because uh with files i'll i'm
not going to talk much with about five
but
uh uh the design assumes that all of
them are possible this is what i mean
okay but but so so
the the the give me a next element
is one thing or potentially i mean
you're mostly a give me a next element
type operation is that right uh
not only because i made an effort to
support uh random access okay whenever
possible okay all right
yeah
okay
so let me start with three examples each
of these examples illustrate things
which are hard or impossible to do well
in the kernel currently
and which which streaming does
so first of all let's start with an
infinite list of primes
so here i'm creating an infinite list of
integers
okay now i'm doing select
on that and notice that it returns a
lazy list but it doesn't do any work yet
uh so it's not conceptually okay listen
either i as a user don't care whether it
didn't work i mean the blob that comes
back for lazy lists should indicate
that oh it's different from the previous
one i mean the id numbers are different
but that isn't really good enough for me
yeah i agree uh
but i mean it could be like it could be
almost like the cryptography system
where all you see is a kind of qr code
and colors that just shows you it's
different it doesn't really matter
because you're probably not going to be
able to show what it really did
but this is a ux in the end yeah we can
yeah i know
i'm i'm just i'm i agree and also i have
to say i i basically cut through to
internals here because
well but anyway i agree with your remark
okay
and so the next thing we do we take a
first million of these primes by
applying take i get it yeah uh and now
if you look at how it looks right now it
looks just an opaque object oh okay okay
but that's not going to cut it because
if i save that in a file i'm toast
well uh the problem with this is that uh
you anyway wouldn't be able to
keep all the
uh infinite content of that no but
that's the wrong thing to keep i mean
what you should keep is the journal
effectively of what you did to get to
that point
presumably that like if that's a point
if that's a memory address or something
presumably whatever structures that is
at the end of that memory address also
is not an infinite list of primes so
um
so so actually i have a slide where i
show how to store this on disk and load
it back
we can move
uh we can easily move some of the
structures inside lazy lists so this is
gonna be easier to do but uh why don't
you just store a function why don't you
just store
literally take of select of lazy range
you know
just um compose the function that you
that you did there yeah right it might
make sense uh right now it's a little
it's not completely lazy because it
pushes certain things to chunks uh
immediately so what you are describing
it might be a better solution is to
offering in it is what you're saying
it's it's buffering some of the data no
it's not really buffering but it's
basically instructs uh well i i can come
to that but basically what's happening
is that in internally this laser list
contains of chunks
not even
the chunks of data
they can be anything but they they have
to be lists
um and so the thing is not all of the
chunks necessarily are even uh realized
as yet some of them might even be we may
be waiting for they might not have been
realized at all
so it's not required at this point but
what steven is saying is that we might
be even more lazy than i was here and
basically
not do anything at this point at all
and just store everything all this chain
of operations in here which might make
sense indeed because what's happening
right now is that certain work is done
but very minimal i'm kind of pushing
this uh work
uh on the chunks so that they know how
to behave but i agree with steven's
comment here yes but you cannot really
avoid
uh being
a need to
recreate
a description of the object after it has
one for a while right if you want to
serialize it so what i've done in in in
my iterator thing which we can probably
talk about next is to have a way of
a method that returns a health
constructor which when evaluated will we
create the whole thing and it will have
all these select and take and everything
still in there
oh yeah i mean this this might be
suboptimal but maybe let me move on
because i think conceptually
changing this is not going to be hard
let me put it this way okay i'm just
curious what's hiding behind the plus
sign
what time behind the plus sign yes
so
there are two objects here i might want
to increase the magnification no no the
verification is fine
leave the magnification okay good
so one object is what is called random
access list
and it's uh it's kind of a
generalization of a list of chunks
and it's a generalization because
not all the chunks are required to be
realized
in the flash
at the time when we look at it
so for instance if i take
oops i'm sorry let me see if i can
did i just
oh
sorry i
seems like i just closed
mathematica
which has been unfortunate but um
um
okay
um
okay so let me go
go back to anywhere
go back to that example go back to that
that was the previous yeah oh it was a
bruise okay um
so
okay go back to your construction for a
second we were still talking about that
yeah okay uh
just need to
um
do a few things here
i hope it will
uh
hope it will work
um
so
um yes um
you were describing the chunking the
random access
uh yes
uh i'm not sure we need to know about
that right yet maybe let's keep going
yeah okay fine i can return to that
later whenever
okay so um
here this example was basically showing
the timing is a little bit off because i
was due to caching but
the main oh yeah we get it we get it you
can you can get it back from it's it's
um it's symbolic form and it's much
faster than doing it yeah i get it okay
good
then there is some random access example
i'm not going to show it i but uh it
basically tells you that you still
maintain okay now wait a second wait a
second when you say total of first mill
primes right
why does that come back
from the indirect representation how
does it know to auto normalize that
yes
okay so here uh let me go to slightly
isn't it because that's a vector to
scalar operation yeah so basically here
is the classification of things uh and
we have to make a decision which two of
them to make lazy and which of them to
make anger
uh the irrelevant one to us is that the
things generally can be classified as
terminal and non-terminal okay
i get it i get it i get it we get it
okay we're quick you know okay great i'm
sure everybody else gets this too
absolutely if it doesn't return a lazy
list then it's then it's ready so so the
design decision that i made so far and
similar one was then for data set but in
a slightly different manner uh was that
anything that is not a lazy list
is basically eager and yeah i got it i
got it i got it i got it right
i mean it would be good if that was
consistently done in data set as well i
don't know if it has been i think it has
been but uh yeah all right okay fine uh
but also some of the operations which
are returning liz list are still so far
implemented eagerly not lazily for
example sorting yeah i get it because
because it doesn't seem to help but
conceptually we should probably have
sort you know i have no idea whether a
partially sorted list for example could
be
additionally sorted in a chunked fashion
or something um well it's done still via
chunking but making it lazy is kind of
hard because it's a very non-local
operation
listen to what i'm saying if it's a
partially sorted list it is not obvious
that it's so non-local
oh yes maybe okay but that's a more
special case i know it is i know the
general case obviously sorting is
non-local
all right so um
so let me go to the next example okay
let's see the random access of tom
what's the random access thing
it's basically shows that uh no matter
where you take your elements
uh
you can maintain
similarly
uh well the the actual
go back to lazy list go back to your
lazy list thing at the beginning there
okay all right go back to your select
integers comma primes okay the primes
thing okay now i want to see primes
uh the 10 millionth element of prime zo
you know
take part 10 million of primes
um okay
oh i don't know well take crimes
primes
primes
opened double brackets
10 million 10 to the seven
ten whatever you want to do
yes like this good yes like that close
the brackets it will take a while but
okay okay let's see it
so what's it doing right now it's going
through the chunked list it's got a
generator and it's going through the
chunk list yes it's going through the
chunks to actually get you the
uh 10 millionth prime
and um no it's not the 10 million prime
is it oh it is yes yes yes because you
requested you requested this yeah
because it's been compressed down to
primes uh yes uh but what also happens
is that
as it goes through the chunks their
sizes get cached
so next time we want to use the the
chunks
as soon as you know which positions you
want you don't necessarily have to go
through the entire process once again
and this is this is this thing this is
this uh
meaning of random access that i mean
that it's kind of amortized random
access certain things like select you
can't have random access immediately
because you don't know what how many
elements you have yeah but if you build
on that select
and if you have run it at least once
then it caches this i guess i get it we
get it we got it get it get it so by the
way i mean obviously in this case okay
it's a little bit more it's a little bit
too much uh okay all right kill it kill
it kill it kill it okay fine if you want
the millions one uh
let's do the hundred thousand one just
to prove to me that it works
okay it was fast because it was already
cached cached right so it doesn't throw
away anything so it's not uh
no it does it's not only caches
all leonid is keeping is the marker of
where the nth
part actually lands okay exactly for the
chunks not for individual elements
right so that i i can always locate
elements very quickly once i went
through it at least once and this one
works if you build something on top of
this primes for you know like chain more
operations etc
like a select another select yes like
another times that uh okay
so so i mean prove that to me just for a
second so take crimes and say select on
primes
selected primes
uh mod of hash comma three equals equals
one
no no
common three
but you know that the prime is equal to
one mod three like this yes like that
exactly
well that's another laser list but we'll
probably you probably want uh it's it's
again infinite so yeah i i know i know i
know that's exactly what i wanted it's
exactly what i wanted now i want the
hundred thousandths one of those take
percent sub a hundred thousand okay no
no no just just percent
oops
why let's try again
it shouldn't work like that
let's see
well
what if i just do
it should have worked
i mean i was trying similar things
before and it was of course working fine
so
so in principle by the way i mean this
new lazy list yeah it's actually using
the same cache as the previous one like
it's it's refers to the previous one
uh
yes uh it refers to the previous one uh
in the more kind of uh so this is
what on earth was the difference between
those two things i can't tell you
immediately soon i am puzzled okay okay
all right fine but but but it act in
this way it works so i have okay i get
it i get it it's beautiful okay let's
keep going okay so um
so now
uh let me go through the next example
which is a large numerical array
here
i'm creating a lazy list out of a
function
which
basically generates me the chunks each
chunk is a million element and i'm
reproducing 200 million elements
in this way
i don't understand that function what on
earth is that
well basically this is this
uh initial function gives you the
content of a chunk given the index
this function actually so you pass the
index it's like a current function
uh so basically if i do
it's like if i do
this thing you're running is basically
table but why is it function of a
million why is the second argument
function of a million why isn't it just
a million
uh well i had to hold it somehow and
potentially it could have been
uh you know some arguments i i in the
future we might want to
make it actually taking some argument so
i'm using this inner function as
basically um
you know a thunk
something which just
holds data i could just as well use hold
here
i think he's talking about the next
argument the function of one mill
oh this thing this is a size function
because that basically whenever you are
creating the
uh lazy list out of the
uh function generator you don't know
exactly you know i know but why is it in
a function why isn't it
the chunks need not all be the same size
right
so
yes
chunk id is coming in as a chunk trunks
serial number is coming in as an
argument to that
uh yes and basically uh this uh this
function here in more general cases it
will be something
more
complicated
okay it will take an index but in this
case because it's a constant thing i i'm
just making the shortcut
ah
so basically but here's the thing uh
now
i'm taking out of this effectively
infinite list built of large chunks i'm
taking 200 million elements
if i'm trying to make normal it will
obviously it won't yeah okay
because i have a limit i have a limit
which you can't actually you can ex you
can expand but yeah i get it i get it
again let me just read lazy list create
for a second here yeah i so what does
that do so that's given the index number
it is giving you
a function
yeah that returns
the
the
elements in that chunk
yes so it's like a chunk to create it's
a it's a chunked version of table
yes it's a chunked version of table
exactly
so it's just one way to create a lazy
list but here i'm using it there are
other ways but here i'm using this way
out of the function
using function
and so
if we perform operations
what happens is that you can do total
and obviously because it's i we are
pretending it's too large to fit in
memory it's like about two gigabytes of
ram but
okay okay okay yes yes and when you if
you compile if if you compile to mvm
it's like still five times slower than
what plays this streaming gives gives
you you can of course compile to c but
still
and here
what this shows is that if i use some
counts by for instance on this large
array of something similar to what you
suggested previously
then a lazy list takes only 16 megabytes
of ram and takes about three minutes
while in memory computation is about 15
percent slower
and it's 100 100 times more memory
hungry
yeah okay so hold on a second so you're
saying
that this laser counts by so those
operations
are so how does this actually work i
mean is is it it's it's going through
it's up values which are directing these
things into uh streaming special
implementations
how many functions have you done that
for
uh i can tell you exactly because i have
a list
of supported api
and so
these are things which are supported
eagerly including accounts
and these are things which are supported
lazily or streaming map is something
yeah okay all right okay i get it so
it's a small number of these functions a
supported laser yes yes okay yes so in
general one could imagine the compiler
in addition to its
type analysis
being able to tell you
for this arbitrary function
which functions in this thing are
supported you know have a i don't know i
mean in other words we could use the
same type of analysis to figure out
because obviously
you should be able to get an arbitrary
function implemented but it's just going
to have to have a callback from each
chunk um
yes uh the problem really is uh in terms
of efficiency at least
that uh you have to be able to factorize
the computation well enough
into something that can be done in
individual chunk i know i know i know i
know i know i know so there's things
that are operations right i i get it
right but that's the point you you can
if the thing has to
do a sort for example where it's taking
everything together and it's an infinite
list and you try and sort an infinite
list
the thing should just say i can't do
that and the type analyzer should be
able to to say that let's try i think it
should complain
let's try sword primes
yeah let's try to live dangerously so by
the way just just for references
probably around for other things as well
how
complicated has it been to
you know to support all of the you know
all of the like the full functionality
of those functions i mean
if you do i mean stuff like you know
maximal buy has to support up to and
things like that uh
well it will become complicated i
actually had to stop but i i was hoping
that it would uh christopher wants one
second i'll just say what happens here i
was hoping that it will complain
uh it didn't for some reason because you
see there is this finite flank here
whenever finite flag is false
i used to think that streaming complains
but uh it didn't do it yet here i don't
know why uh i have to think look at it
at it uh now about you're not showing
false it's showing question mark right
yeah question mark is for primes uh for
primes it doesn't know that's why
there's a question mark
so you did sort of primes not sort of
integers yeah let's try sort of integers
it doesn't it it didn't get the message
from euclid okay let's list as defined
were explicitly fine at least
the problematic list was well the the
error message might not be ideal but
still on that but so notice that that
next thing as i said on line 31 it
didn't get the message from euclid that
they're an infinitive primes
uh yes
right but the point is that that that
analysis of whether that's finite like
if i'd said twin prime there we have no
idea we don't know whether it's infinite
or not yes
right so
yeah uh sure it probably should have
stopped even whenever it's unclear
because here it says that the list is
finite so i i'm doing some yeah
the point that i'm making is that there
is an analysis like type analysis
which is essentially a cardinality
analysis
could be could be similarly done i don't
know that's obvious from type theory how
one would do that i mean it seems like
it's just it might be super undecidable
though i mean like you just said with
the primes one there's no way it can
know that
uh right but it's it's like a dependent
type theory right it's very similar to
dependent type theory because it's
basically saying the type is integers
but it has this you know it has this
condition like primes
well but i mean it just seems like it
just seems like you know it doesn't
matter what crazy type system you have
you're not going to be able to to do the
uh selection no i know but
in many cases you will be able to do it
and that's the same thing
type theory right okay let's keep going
keep going we can't solve the general
dependent type problem because it's
undecidable and this is an example of
that
yes and to quickly answer the question
of christopher uh it will go it's going
to be rather hard to support the entire
functionality of all those functions
but
in many cases what i'm doing i'm trying
to kind of piggyback on the existing
implementations and pushing those to the
individual chunks so the actual
implementations of these things
sometimes are very simple
so that makes it not really hopeless but
supporting all the range like up to and
things like that might be kind of
involved
uh so
onward yeah onward uh now uh okay this
way okay this is the first
thing we've seen that
here
i think yes uh saw this we saw it with
all this and we saw that the in-memory
uh version it's magnificently smaller
right yeah i mean
you're
you're you're lazy chunking thing is
magnificently smaller by the way i
assume
that when you exit the session
everything just
um
uh
just
it's all cleaned up i mean this has a
bunch of files hanging around
but they all clean up
ah they should be i have to check
whether uh uh how well this works but
i did some work on that and they should
be clean be cleaned up and also are they
in the temp directory should they be
launched should they be creating an
attempt directory in case yes they are
they are direct they are they are
created in some sub directory of attempt
directory okay
and also some of the chunks are not file
backed even like for instance this
infinite primes because i guess yeah
okay you don't need you don't need
anything big
yeah because they are generated by
function so um
although i can optionally instruct that
they have to be filed back if that
function is expensive okay
now this is an implementation of moving
moving average which shows that you can
actually do
implement things using the framework
uh and kind of getting new things out of
it
uh and it's just uh kind of making us
kind of translating one of the famous
mathematical implementations of moving
average where you just shift large
arrays
uh and kind of transpose them
and then if you um
so lazy list transpose so most of what
you're doing with with these lazy lists
is is one-dimensional one-level lists
right you've got an infinite one-level
list
what is lazy
okay so you can do two-dimensional
chunking some in some sense yes uh it
doesn't really yeah it does work and uh
it well i'll let you put it this way
uh
the chunk has to be a list but the
elements of that list can be anything
that they can be lists themselves okay
but so internet so you are only chunking
with respect to the top level of the
nested list array yeah that's true
that's correct
yes so lazy list transpose
is that a cheap operation or is that a
horrendously expensive operation
because i suspect every chunk
that's a cheap operation because it
doesn't do anything in advance
it basically oh i see it's just array
it's just an array gymnastics thing yes
uh and then what that's exactly what i'm
illustrating here uh so i'm having here
the um lazy list of 10 million elements
but by the way i just want to comment on
something that kind of array gymnastics
stuff when we were talking previously
about scaffolded arrays that's another
thing one could imagine doing with them
it's some kind of transposit you know
it's some kind of basically trivial
transposition
um
yeah here it's a little more complex
because it's cha you have to take
chunking into account but otherwise yes
okay well actually it's pretty
complicated with the scaffolded arrays
too because i mean for example with
quantity array
you know when you take the transpose
it's pretty easy but if you have uh
if the same framework is also used for
the column-based association your
column-based arrays basically then a
transpose like an association transpose
which is a very different operation yes
that is correct right yeah because of
the because of the fact that the
uh
you know associations have
are uniquified
that's the reason right christopher that
that's what i mean it's just that the
reason i think it's just that that it's
because
you know the scaffold in quantity array
the scaffolding wraps around a single
element right as opposed to having one
sort of piece of scaffolding wrapping
several elements
i you know i i don't agree with that i
mean if if we if we're storing
uh right the the the
right if we have an association of lists
and we're saying oh secretly
this is you know representing a list of
associations well then the transpose
operation is no this is now truly right
that's just a flag saying no this is now
truly an association of lists rather
than secretly a list of associations so
that one will be okay that one there's
no equivalency worry
all right anyway that's sorry that was
off topic let's see
one one tangential comment i have for
this is that uh since laser list doesn't
largely care what are the chunks those
chunks could as well be this efficient
uh table or data structures as soon as
we have them
and it will be
very easy to accommodate inside
streaming
can the trunk be itself a lazy list
in principle yes uh and i think i had
some examples but not here where it was
the case but in general
it's becoming hard if you kind of nest
if you if you nest the laziness because
you have to since lazy list doesn't
support all the operations of the
individual chunk you have them to be
careful what that what the thing is
okay
okay uh
so let me let me show what this thing or
what uh what the the point of this
example is
uh so here is a reasonably concise
implementation
and then uh i'm asking for the moving
average with the window five
and what this uh
shows hopefully
is that even though it's uh 10 million
elements
because of the way lazy transpose works
you don't have to compute the full
lazy moving average to compute the parts
that you're interested in like ten
thousand elements yeah i guess i get it
and if you look at the max memory use
here for the entire thing now i'm making
normal so it's it's
it's basically all
uh converted to
normal then it's like eight seconds and
it's about
uh 100 megabytes
uh here it used to be 50 i don't know
why it raised to twice but the point is
for the moving average in the kernel for
the same thing
it's like four times slower and eight
times more memory than the streaming
implement okay
that's nice so here so here we are
already beating the kernel both in
runtime and in memory
um
now um
where to go from here uh
okay so
by the way for the kernel one reason
you're beating it in run time is because
the kernel computed everything and then
threw away most of it whereas you're
only computing the part you need correct
no no no steven i beat the kernel on the
entire computation and that's
let me
let me show again
the partial computations are here
here i'm doing normal of the entire
thing
why did you win against the kernel on
the on the entire thing i think because
of the memory allocation and because of
the algorithms that kernel uses
internally okay
that's interesting but that's my guess
okay all right okay fine
um
now
uh
i just wanted to explain a few
additional things if you think that
there is still time
basically i wanted to briefly go through
the typical streaming workflow that you
have to obviously construct it somehow
from external data yes let's see it open
it open well it doesn't have any
examples it just has
some
i understand that but go ahead right
okay now the other few things i want to
very briefly touch would be
can we look more at construction do you
in fact have examples of construction do
you have a design how the construction
would work
yes uh in general there are three ways
i'm supporting right now
either it's explicit data where you just
have the data in the kernel and then you
just say okay what size of chunk you
have if you don't say i think there is
some defaults on chunk size
uh okay so that's going that's just
saying i want to chunk this now but i
already had the whole thing as opposed
to a generator
yes yes that's right uh it's of
relatively uh i mean
uh the number of cases where you would
really need this is probably not not
very big because if you already i i get
it if you already have it then you
already have it yeah uh then the most
important thing i think is to construct
it from the object which i call licitera
list iterator and which where i think my
work overlaps with the work of roman and
maybe other other people in the company
because i have internally a kind of
interface defined inside streaming which
is called
uh
list iterator and so basically any
source that is implementing this list
iterator can be consumed by streaming
in this case i'm having this
make data list iterator out of explicit
data but there are other iterators which
can be built uh out of other things and
i have actually an example of such let
me see
quickly jump to that
uh but fundamentally the idea of an
iterator is it's a give me the next
element type thing is that right
yes except in here i'm extending it to
say give me next chunk of elements okay
fine
just for speed
uh
let me see if i
i should have it somewhere
yes enrollment how does this relate to
what you've built
well the main difference to my
iterators is that my iterators
are
mutable and so they consume
they you cannot go back right
it it's it's it's it's strictly for
accessing elements one at a time which
of course then extends to functions like
select where you might have to access
more than one element
until you find the next result and so on
so mine is strictly about
iterators which are most useful probably
for combinatorial generators like all
give me all the binary trees but not all
at the same time but given the next
binary tree
then many of our operations work just as
well
uh one element at a time then if you
generate all the elements first
right i mean it's not trivial some
algorithms do not like binary trees
there might be a recursive algorithm for
generating that that does not make it
easy to go one at a time
yeah i mean there is that i mean for for
binary tweets the problem is solved you
just looking knows the out of computer
programming and yes lots of
uh
this particular case yes is
it's it's rather efficient to generate
the binary trees one by one if you
compile them if you compile the
algorithm
of course no but i'm saying there are
plenty of cases where it is not the case
that it there is no trivial
transformation from a recursive program
that generates a complete collection of
things to a program that generates them
one at a time that is not real
if there isn't one then then you cannot
use that that paradigm okay fine yeah
right okay but so it's a give me the
next element or give me a certain
numbered element perhaps
is it give me the next element or does
it give me the element
at the lowest level it it's very basic
it just
requires you to have a function that
returns the next element
now of course
higher up you can easily extend that
give me the next
give me
yeah okay case element and there are two
cases if you do nothing it will just use
the trivial implementation just
uh it's a common blanket five times
right super common like combinatoric is
full of these we call them ranking
functions
and if one iterator does have a more
efficient way of generating the fifth
element without
the other four before it can always
overload that generic implementation
then it will become
as efficient as possible i mean like for
example good example is
map
the output
lazy list is the same size as the input
so it's quite easy if the input supports
look ahead then the output does as well
but if you do a select then you lose
that and there's no way to jump ahead
without computing everything in between
[Music]
yeah that's that's that's true okay
let's see this
okay so what this is it basically
creates a an iterator for lazy list
which reads a file
one string at a time so unit of work
here is a string
so uh this is an implementation it
basically is uh
have an interface that one has to
implement basically one has to implement
four functions initialization next
element
uh closing and
asking whether it's still active and
closing surely by the way design wise
those should be in an association
yeah absolutely this was done before i
think this was done
probably before associations became a
thing or at least shortly after a while
ago okay all right yeah uh but yeah uh
surely uh and then there is another
thing called writer which is another
interface where you have to
uh basically implement uh opening the
right then the right next chance okay
good then the next thing you do
you
uh register this
writer and reader and then uh here i'm
importing
the us constitution text
and now uh there's this lazy list import
which
is a function for laser list but
it could conceivably be integrated with
the import at some point but
so this is a name of this format that we
have defined and here we go we have a
lazy list out of this new format
and now you can basically access it
element wise or you can export it
okay so the fundamental point here is
just like in import you can ask for this
element or that element you can ask for
a data set you can ask for this or that
what you're saying is imagine a case
where you could ask for a lazy list
yeah even though
in that case
one feature of import is
after you've imported something you
could throw away the file and it's still
good what you imported is still good in
this case there's still a you know an
umbilical cord so to speak connecting
the imported thing to the original
source
not always it depends on how you do it
you can do it eagerly and create a lazy
list so that it will be read entirely or
you can keep kind of yeah i get it i get
it i get it so one case is that it
streams everything through your
framework and then delivers you a
separate
immutable copy so to speak you know
okay
all right so that case will be the case
that would be natural for import
you know if you think of media audio and
video
so let's say that you stream things
you know initially we did things where
you download the whole thing locally
so it doesn't go into memory but it's
still local
yeah and then the other case is that you
don't do that you want to be able to
show it kind of right away as soon as
you buffered enough type thing
right so this is basically a streaming
import versus say you know versus
ordinary import with a lazy list element
exactly and actually uh streaming
supports both i just didn't have an
example for
the one which will be kind of lazy in
terms of impressing but
it is inside yeah okay okay okay so for
streaming
you know you sometimes don't know the
end of it
so for instance let's say it's a sensor
that keeps reporting new data
yes or you know it's true for video too
we don't sometimes know the end of it it
could be live for instance but but even
when it's not live you you can always
query the length of it
oh um yes it's still supported uh which
is why in a lazy list
when i have this uh in internals there
is this random access list here of
chunks
this thing generalizes normal list to
the case where not all chunks have been
already materialized
so
it allows you to add chunks as they
appear in principle so could this be
hooked up to a sensor that keeps yeah i
guess
i guess it could although
it would be sort of interesting to see
how to make things sort of non-blocking
when the new data arrive
how would you you can of course re
request all the time and it will show
you but uh
it's it's probably the wrong model
probably it's the wrong i think it's the
wrong model because i think it's gonna
get the blocking thing the concept that
something from outside the process can
block you
seems inconvenient for this yes i agree
but also if you think of a sensor that
runs forever
the fact that you think that you're
going to tell it up in a long list seems
like wrong
yeah okay onward okay so uh perhaps the
uh
well there is something i wanted to very
briefly show is that you can basically
persist
i have this lazy list put which allows
you to
purchase disks on uh persist lazy list
on disk and then lazy list get to get it
back
uh and uh so that this uh
uh this way you can serialize things for
be available for the new sessions i
didn't really want to put too many i
mean there's more to design around that
i don't think that's exactly the right
way to do it
i mean well maybe functionality-wise
this may be fine but i don't think
that's how it should be presented to the
user probably i'm sure it was more just
to say that this aspect is kind of has
been considered but i'm not saying that
and the last thing i wanted to show very
quickly is
the um
you know leonard i do love the way that
you you put the phrase very quickly
never mind keep going i i'm no but i
like you okay okay uh construction 33
slides tells you something okay so
okay so let let's try to do do this in
one minute okay this slide and this will
be the last okay okay uh so
uh i'm just wanting i just wanted to
show that it's pretty easy to extend the
framework let's say the standard
deviation is not yet in the framework
which is true
and well it's obviously you can obvious
formal how you compute this
and now uh what you do
is that you make an implementation like
here which is the streaming
implementation
then uh you can basically test things
and again
i'm well i can as well run it but uh the
thing is uh it's going to be
uh
is going to be basically much more
memory efficient than the in memory
thing
uh while slightly slower but then you
can register the implementation
like this and then they can use standard
deviation that this system
so okay my question is this lazy-less
chunk fold for example how many
creatures like that are there how many
functions are there uh
just maybe two or three uh i don't
believe you we've already seen at least
10.
we've seen all kinds of lazy lists
create we've seen all these things what
are the special lazy list functions
just type question mark lazy list or
lazy star
lazy star
yeah but not all of them have to be
exported to the top level so the
question is
uh obviously which one uh which ones the
user would may may want to use
which
which which ones of these are there that
are of that type
which you would seriously use in
implementation
of a lazy list construct
um
well i would say
probably these three and maybe
a couple of more but i think
they are definitely below below that
their number is definitely below 10.
okay
i and even they are actually done here
for used here for performance you could
just as well use fold
but in that case i wouldn't be able to
make this thing as fast as this because
this instructs it
essentially to do things per chunk
and bypass anything well so one
possibility would be a headdress
for a bunch of functions absolutely
because because we have a similar
headrest with batch applied
right
yes
what is the relationship between batch
applied and chunking
oh there is no relationship currently
but i realized
but i'm using
i'm using internally something similar
to batch bashes so
we can see if there are so let's look at
whether that because that would be i
mean in fact we had a question on the
live stream which i've been kind of
ignoring here from ethan about chunking
database queries and that would be that
is what batch applied is doing is it not
uh but not in relation to databases i
think
because uh okay it's really it's in
relation to the entity framework uh yes
uh and for the database
yeah go ahead yeah what else like with
respect to all this stuff with
the headdress and special functions and
also to answer about databases
i think that
the approach that tom has been using for
data structure is very very promising
because in
you can define a number of these
low-level functions that only work with
a certain data structure within the data
structure as well as methods
and
you use those i mean
the idea would be i get that i get it i
get it so instead of lazy list trunk
fold you have a lazy list data structure
the the the thing lazy list is a data
structure right
a tom styles
i mean that would work unbelievably well
by the way
i'm not sure it can be a data structure
data
actually an actual structure because
data structure is documented to have as
it could be something else it does yeah
but why can't it be a data structure why
couldn't this structure
has the the the full data in like the
second argument
that that can't work for for out of
course stuff well i should have a
serialization and a visualization yes
that's that's right so we could redefine
that but but the concept of fitting this
into data structure seems rather good to
me because then we don't have to have
all of this
you know then that lazy-less chunk fold
just becomes
a you know a data structure operation
which we need to write better you know
write better design for
but
on this thing we don't have to have
another whole
world of anyway i i that sounds like a
good idea to me yeah and and by the way
i'll just say data structures also have
iterators and writing that mean you know
you just implement the iterator and then
lots of other functions just start
working by
you know by the way the the type system
in the compiler works so you just
implement the iterator and then you can
start i think there's something leonard
needs to learn about yeah yeah uh yeah
um it could be a new thing that we start
i mean maybe it's not data structure
because many people think of linked
lists and other things
say it's a data model so it's it's it's
it's kind of like a set of interfaces
to data
kind of like data structure is in a way
we have a nice internal mechanism for
working with these things through the
compiler that's that's that's for sure i
think
yeah yeah but but see i'm kind of
thinking that
you know think of of this going on for
for a number of years and we are going
to connect all kinds of outer core
um
data you know data models basically you
know and how we distribute operations
between
things that are run very close to data
and very close to
you know the compute
uh you know where you do your your main
compute
that's going to change over time
i'm saying i could imagine that we have
even distributed data models
you know that's very uncommon now we are
happy to have one out of core sort of
data source but let's say that we have
several of them
it's not relevant right now but it might
be in five years
um yeah but
there's one thing that we were talking
about with the last time i think
christopher said it which is if we have
like a smallish interface for all these
kind of low-level data structures
and and then then we have a number like
out of core in-core and whatnot of these
data structures which all have a similar
interface then
you can have a higher level construct
that consumes this stuff and implements
sort using the lower level stuff or
intersection and so on i think that's a
very powerful idea because then you're
kind of obstructing away the single
implementation and it's the job of uh
you know
of the higher level data structure say
oh sort is done by this lower level
operations
yes
that makes sense okay
we have to wrap this meeting in a moment
but we have a few comments from our live
stream which i think might be
interesting to look at here
um
let's see
um
let's see is it possible to pass a
single copy of the array variable so
that is shared between all available
kernels and processors
not talking about set shared variable
but rather shared by default so there's
some questions about parallelism here
and i assume that once you're chunking
you could in principle be running
different chunks on different processes
is that a true statement uh well the
true statement would be that the design
of streaming doesn't prevent that
and roman can you comment on how that
would be yeah but i mean you would have
to send all the data back and forth
yeah i mean if you can paralyze the
constructor so that
the
each kernel would
just create
the the chunks that it has been assigned
to completely so that's what i would do
all the time with parallel yes i mean it
would make a lot of sense let's say that
multi-core like like you know multi you
know run these things in multiple
threads that's that then you don't have
to move data around oh and but by the
way uh regarding this i wanted to make a
few remarks uh
for compiler that
uh streaming is pretty agnostic to what
kind of things it passes to the chunks
so
i did experiments it can pass for
instance compiled predicates etc and one
of the directions to speed it up
would have been to integrate it was the
new compiler and be able to pass
complications on chunks to the
basically pass compiled functions
uh yeah sure no that that
absolutely and
parallelism structures yeah and data
structures is a source for your chunks
and just to to mention that something i
forgot earlier that so uh really if you
could help me just type parallel map of
f comma
range 1 million just so i have something
to show
and so this
range one this all this does not expand
the range on the master curl
it dissects it symbolically
and sends the range commands to the
other curls
so this already does something similar
but it recognizes range as a constructor
and
it avoids the i had no idea about that
roman because i have this i have done
this i have by hand done a version of
this many times
that's pretty old but but one thing is
that if each core has separate access to
storage let's say so it's effectively a
parallel storage access
you know and you and you're drawing from
something that that's big
then then we should make more functions
that can do i mean every one of our
kernels does have its own i o system
but i don't think we've made it super
easy to do right now
but it's one of these okay so that's
one item here with respect to
you know so you're talking about shared
file system access yeah yeah yeah
exactly shared file system or other
shared storage you know but they all can
sort of separately access it so it's
parallel
okay
yeah and i guess the design of streaming
currently doesn't prevent any of that in
in other words it wouldn't be hard to
generalize to that because nothing there
really is fundamentally
you know preventing this
right
okay
let's have an external appointment yeah
i also have to go in a moment um but but
we had a few comments here i just wanted
to look at them from ethan here
um
suggesting use cases
okay
data science and high frequency trading
detection of causation between terabytes
of time series
i don't know i mean that's a
i mean you could want to do many
different things there it's unclear to
me what
uh
okay second one
go ahead yeah i mean the main issue is
if you have anything apply a function to
data that you don't already have in
memory
or already avoid reading in everything
at the beginning at all costs and so i
think that's that's exactly what these
these examples are about
okay well storing super large image and
video data sets with lots of labels for
different types
for evaluating
multiple tasks so that's an issue of
more like the scaffolded arrays where
you have
these big
images and that's another use for
scaffolded arrays is where you have some
big image asset in the background and
what you're doing is essentially array
gymnastics and you only pull in the big
image asset when you look at that we
think it's a pretty rare use case that
you have super big images but what's
super common is that you have big image
collections no i agree that's right
right
where you've got a million image
collections exactly exactly the backbone
of a million labels is nothing
it's the images that back them that's
huge that's exactly how you know machine
learning kind of works in that same
same way
but but you have to pay attention yeah
because you might have like there are
databases that are so huge that even the
metadata
can blow up your memory i know but let's
assume that we're not dealing with that
case
that's there's two levels here you know
there's a factor of a million difference
between the metadata blowing up your
memory
and the assets blowing up your memory so
you can live in that factor of a million
easily
um
okay another so that is another case we
should look at another one
uh the etl case working with streaming
data from kafka
interesting
um
i don't know whether we've talked about
that as a streaming source
i mean we're using that ourselves now
for a bunch of things
but does it leonard can you or anybody
else here can you comment on streaming
sources like kafka
well um i don't have any uh experience
with kafka yet but i would assume that
it should be possible to connect also
through
but that requires that that what we
don't have right now is a version of
import that is essentially a streaming
import that connects to a stream like a
kafka source
yes
right and actually that's kind of a
symbolic import
that connects to a stream which is what
we were talking about before with
roger's sensors and so on i mean a kafka
stream is like a sensor data stream
exactly
um
yeah i had somewhere i was looking for
some note that we need the streaming
import but i can't find it but uh it was
somewhere noted right but you see but
streaming import what we need is
something which simply returns and it's
very similar to what we do in the device
framework it simply returns and we
should look at the device framework the
device framework may already have solved
this problem
right remember the device framework is
looking for data that could be buffered
might be unbuffered
but is data from the future so to speak
so why don't you look at the device
framework and see if that can be used
for the streaming stuff
yeah that's uh that's a good idea
okay and
yeah just one last thing i wanted to say
regarding all this i think overall
my picture of lazy list and streaming is
that whenever you can think of something
as a list conceptually which exists
somewhere not necessarily in memory
then what streaming does it provides you
this list like abstraction to operate on
using familiar functions uh while it
will do all the work underneath that's
what it does
and in particular it's kind of
orthogonal to
what possible content of that list might
be for instance that might be you know
chunks of this double structures or
something else as long as it is a list
it should be able to operate on it
um
okay there was another comment from
ethan here unsupervised data science
clustering on gigabytes of json data
from a web scraping job
i don't know that that's
requires more thought
um
let's see nick is suggesting
more lazy a symbolic thunk that only
unthunks on demand
and can be realized as an attribute for
any symbol
well that's much more general thing how
is that different from like hold
i'm not sure that it is the point that
if you apply a function it applies to
the inside well i think well i think
what nick is suggesting here which is
kind of an interesting idea that we've
never had before
is
a
just like we can say x colon equals blah
that's somehow i actually don't know how
this makes any sense
that somehow the thing that is returned
as the value of x
is always itself held it doesn't make it
it requires more thought that's not
quite right
um
one thing i wanted to comment on here is
that being always lazy is kind of
dangerous because when you start nesting
laziness you very quickly lose control
over which operations are performed when
and on efficiency as well
sure
um
yeah ali is commenting 40 image stacks
can also be large
i think 4d image stacks should be
you know in any streaming lazy
thing that can work with backbone plus
that should work
all right this was an interesting demo
um
i think there's a number of connections
that need to be made here and i guess we
have to keep going
on you know we need to dig into the
design of the scaffolded arrays stuff
and that will be both
top level functional design and internal
implementation design
and you know we i think we've got these
three areas here
does anybody think that there's any are
these well actually there's a there's a
different one
which is uh essentially
um
uh
asset separated arrays
i don't know if that's really different
eg
backbone plus images metadata
metadata blackbone
plus
um
well
there is another category that we were
looking at which is basically um
it's in core
but it's not your usual uh wolfram
language memory
um
[Music]
layout
well like the compiler would do work in
some way
um like the compiler would do the
compiler is using its own memory layout
yeah pretty much but it might be an
external process but still memory
okay
all right well this was useful let's um
keep going let's do this again next week
i guess
um
since this week we have a lot of stuff
uh
towards the end of the week for the 13
um
preparation
um
okay anything else anybody wants to add
right now
nope okay good stuff thanks to folks
here and thanks to folks on the live
stream